[Music]
breaking news tonight
chaos on capitol hill
pro-trump protesters invade america's
corridors of power
our democracy is under unprecedented
assault also breaking this wednesday
night
quebec's new crackdown the upcoming
curfew and closures as the second wave
surges plus the new rules about to
descend on anyone flying into canada
and the lingering questions
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
[Music]
a dark and dangerous moment in america's
modern history
donald trump supporters stormed the u.s
capitol where lawmakers were getting
ready to certify
joe biden's election win instead
senators and representatives were locked
down
while a mob invaded the chaos highlights
the
how much power the outgoing president
has over his followers
who are trying to overthrow democracy
good evening and thank you for joining
us while all that was happening
president trump stayed well hidden in
the white house
earlier at a rally today he riled up his
supporters spewing more
baseless allegations of election fraud
and calling for the results to be
overturned
so his defenders took matters into their
own hands
a crowd breached the barriers at what
should have been one of the most secure
places in d.c
it took more than an hour before trump
called for peace
by that point a shot had been fired
inside the capitol building and a
warning
the footage we're about to show you is
disturbing
a woman was shot while apparently trying
to climb through a broken window
metropolitan police tell global news she
was shot in the neck
and has since died from her injuries
tonight u.s lawmakers are getting back
down to business in the capitol
and they're condemning the mob's actions
unfortunately
we can now add january 6 2021
to that very short list of dates in
american history
that will live forever in infamy
this temple to democracy was desecrated
they tried to disrupt our democracy
they failed they failed
they failed to attempt to obstruct the
congress this failed insurrection
only underscores how crucial the task
before us
is for our republic
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow joins us now from d.c
jackson let's talk about congress and
how it's trying to repair the nation
tonight
well robin they're right back where they
left off before this attempted
insurrection holding a debate at this
hour over the electoral college result
in the state of arizona but this has
essentially
devolved into simply lawmakers from both
sides talking about the violence at the
capitol building today
one thing you won't hear from
republicans though is any sort of finger
pointing at president trump or
his enablers for fomenting this violence
democrats though
are accusing the president of fomenting
this violence
and essentially that seems to be where
things are now headed tonight now it
does seem
that they will in fact finish counting
joe biden's electoral college win this
evening
it also seems many of the republicans
are now lifting their objections the
roadblocks that they had thrown up in
this process
and it means it could be a much shorter
debate than we were originally expecting
robin
when president trump finally spoke to
his followers it was
a video on twitter he called for calm
but did fan the conspiracy flames
let's listen we had an election that was
stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order jackson
twitter has now deleted that video
and locked trump's account for 12 hours
as a result of this
ongoing violent situation but the damage
is done
will his message set the stage for a
similar scene when biden is inaugurated
which is two weeks from now
the next 14 days are incredibly perilous
in this country robin not just here in
washington d.c but in cities and states
right across the country we've seen
similar pro-trump protests
take place at governor's mansions and
state houses across the country
some state governors have had to move
into secure locations for their own
safety as a result of this
and it seems as though there could still
be further attempts to try and disrupt
the inauguration of biden especially
once reality sets in for trump
and his supporters after congress
finished its work sometime overnight
tonight so there's tremendous concern
about those security questions here
it also seems quite likely though that
president trump is going to find himself
increasingly isolated during his final
days in office and what we're seeing are
large numbers of members of congress
either calling for him to be impeached
again
calling for the invocation of the 25th
amendment to remove trump from
office or essentially resigning from the
administration and i would not be
surprised if we see a large-scale
resignation from the administration a
large number of officials
in various levels departing out of sheer
discuss with what happened tonight
the first out the door is the
spokesperson for the first lady so
robin it's already started has security
increased since
today's developments yes
the national guard is here in washington
d.c state troopers u.s marshals they're
all over the city they're securing and
fortifying the capitol building so this
work can continue
of course robin there's going to be lots
of questions about why those measures
weren't taken in
advance knowing that there was so much
tension around today
but that's a question for another day at
this point jackson prescott in
washington thank you so much for today
tonight prime minister justin trudeau
tweeted about the situation in
washington saying canadians are deeply
disturbed and saddened by the attack on
democracy in the united states
our closest ally and neighbor violence
will never succeed in overruling the
will of the people
democracy in the u.s must be upheld and
it will be
voters not only sent joe biden to the
white house democrats will now have
control of the senate a hotly contested
runoff election in georgia
ended with two democratic senators
heading to washington
here's how those two races played out
reverend rafael warnock took
republican kelly lefler's seat with 50.6
percent
of the vote and then there was an even
tighter race democrat john
ossoff appears to have squeaked out a
victory over david perdue
ahead by less than half a percent these
two wins
paved the way for biden to push forward
with his vision
for a post-trump america as eric
sorenson explains
georgia turning blue is seen as a clear
rebuke to the way the u.s
has been governed for the past four
years
raphael warnock the first southern black
democrat elected to the u.s senate
ever the pastor from the same baptist
church as martin luther king
his win alone is historic but i've
brought people together
across racial lines religious lines that
american promise is alive and well
after all i'm sitting here but there is
more history in the works
a close vote trending to a second
democrat in georgia john ossoff who's
already claiming victory
and i will look forward to serving you
in the united states senate with
integrity
the georgia races may be squeakers but
they are potentially a culmination of a
tectonic shift in power in washington
in the november election the democrats
in blue retained control of the house of
representatives
the trump pence ticket lost shifting the
white house to the democrats
with biden and harris in the senate the
republicans led 50 to 48
the two georgia seats could make that 50
to 50
and the tiebreaker goes to the sitting
vice president and in two weeks
that will be kamala harris she could be
the 51st vote in the senate
potentially putting the democrats on the
verge of controlling not just the senate
but all three branches of government the
hurdles before us are many
and they are serious a capital long
dominated by the power of republican
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
is suddenly within the grasp of democrat
chuck schumer for too long much needed
help
has been stalled or diluted by a
republican-led senate
and president trump that will change
with control of the senate president joe
biden will have a clearer path for a
progressive agenda
the senate seats are truly the
last line of defense president trump's
claims of voter fraud likely suppressed
the republican vote in georgia
further dividing his own party i think a
lot of it will get blamed
on uh on donald trump we're seeing
really a split now
in the republican party we'll see just
how deep it goes between those who stay
loyal to trump
and those who just want to put him in
the past as quickly as possible
the president's desperation to stay in
the white house may have cost
republicans the senate
and donald trump may have diminished his
party and his presidency
on his way out the door eric sorenson
global news
now to some breaking news here in canada
after weeks of surging coronavirus case
numbers
quebec is imposing a strict
province-wide curfew
this is the province's trajectory it's
been 12 days since tough measures took
effect
and case numbers are still surging today
there were more than 2600 new infections
and 47 more people died quebec premiere
francois lego says the situation
is now critical and he has no option but
to impose
even stricter measures to get the crisis
under control
global's mike armstrong is in montreal
tonight mike take us through these
measures starting with the curfew
sure that is the big thing that's being
announced tonight that curfew the new
rules
will come into effect this coming
saturday this weekend
the big one that curfew it'll be for
four weeks basically from 8 p.m to 5 a.m
aside from going outside for work or for
health reasons overnight
people can't be outside that'll go until
the 8th of february
there was a hammer to this measure
people can be fined for not respecting
the curfew
one thousand to six thousand dollars
other measures in this sort of enhanced
lockdown being announced non-essential
stores closed already since december
25th will stay closed
also until february 8th grocery stores
and convenience stores
are being asked to close at 7 30 so
people can get home
for that curfew only gas stations and
pharmacies
are allowed to stay open now as for
schools that's been a big one for
parents
closed since december 17th well
elementary schools will reopen
as scheduled monday high schools won't
be reopening right away they're going to
do an extra week of
online classes now why all these
measures the premier says
this is a race against time the va the
excuse me the
virus is moving too quickly he has to
slow it down to save the health care
system he says
and that's going to take what he calls
shock therapy robin
mike armstrong in montreal thanks mike
for the second day in a row new
brunswick has broken
its record for daily new infections 31
new cases were reported today
that brings the total number of active
cases to 110.
just one week ago there were only 28
active infections in new brunswick
the province's top doctor says holiday
gatherings are to blame
she's warning the province to brace for
more
as grim as it looks today things will
likely get worse before they get better
everyone must act now to follow public
health guidance and advice
the alternative is even stricter public
health measures to counter the spread of
this disease
all of new brunswick is now in the
orange phase of restrictions
people are being asked to stick to a one
household bubble
face masks are mandatory in all indoor
public spaces
as of midnight tonight anyone coming
into canada from abroad will have to
show proof of a negative kova 19 test
the federal government rushed in the new
requirement and that has the industry
scrambling
as abigail beeman reports the big
concern is how the new rule
will be enforced thailand wants tourists
to come back
so off we go these canadians hitting the
skies are aware of the new rules they'll
need a negative pcr test within 72 hours
of their flight home
i agree with the policy we have people
who have canceled and we also have
people
in destination right now while this
travel agent's business is down
90 percent there are still many
canadians in destination
around the world left scrambling eight
to nine hours on the phone calling
several hospitals civic centers urgent
care centers private practitioners
just to try and get this test brutal i
mean it's absolutely ruined uh
this vacation i've spent the last three
days trying to figure out how to get
a cova test i don't know if i'm going to
get shoved into some
detention center i am getting tested
twice next wednesday
in the hopes that somebody will succeed
wednesday the federal government
announced people like arthur mitchell in
mexico
and canadians in locations including the
caribbean south america and ethiopia
can provide a test from within 96 hours
but that exception only lasts until next
week with some further
limited exceptions for haiti and the
french islands off newfoundland and
labrador
the consulate wasn't answering kovid
related calls the extensions don't help
many in the united states
told test results take up to seven days
like harpreet singh mon trying to return
to canada for child
care help it just seems like a complete
mess the way they've
rolled these rules out there was no
thought put into it this is exactly why
we're
advising people to not travel
internationally
it is difficult to acquire a pcr test in
countries that you wouldn't suspect that
it's difficult to acquire one
the airline industry responsible for
checking tests at boarding
has been calling for more time we are
going to now have to
deny those people boarding and their
return flights to canada so
we are still concerned about the the
potential for confusion
and the the potential of stranding
people
in in foreign countries because they
have not been able to meet their
requirements at this point
along with the new test requirements
also comes an end to the ban on flights
from the uk
but ottawa is clear a negative test does
not replace
a 14-day quarantine anyone entering
canada still needs to follow
those rules abigail beeman global news
ottawa
another day another apology for a
tropical vacation
coming up this time it's a doctor and a
hospital ceo
a hospital ceo in ontario is facing
fallout for a trip he took over the
holidays
dr tom stewart who sat on a provincial
covet 19 advisory panel
went on vacation to the dominican
republic despite public health advice
not to travel stewart has since
apologized and resigned from several
advisory groups
but as mike delay reports that hasn't
quelled frustrations in a province
struggling with the pandemic
the new year is usually full of hope and
empty streets in toronto would seem to
suggest the current covet 19 lockdown
is being adhered to premier doug ford
has tough decisions to make
but he'll have one less expert to call
on dr tom stewart who makes
thousand dollars as a ceo of niagara's
hospital system
resigned as an advisor to ford after it
came to light he had traveled to the
dominican republic
after ford urged ontarians to stay home
he has since apologized and deleted
tweets where he was critical of
ontarian's
reckless and selfish behavior and in
another
a lack of provincial leadership the head
of ontario's hospital union says the 13
000 physicians and staff who work for dr
stewart are overworked
and now unhappy you know there's a set
of rules for them
which is uh weekends are cancelled
vacations are cancelled holidays are
canceled
and you know one of the people who's
leading them in this battle
is not actually in the battle at all but
it's off for all ford's problems with
the pandemic
he can't shake questions about the issue
of leadership and privilege
and he refused to give a straight answer
about others who may have ignored the
rules
i made it very clear to everyone not to
travel and i
made it very clear to our caucus and
cabinet in effect
it by not responding it's an admission
and more is going to come out and it's
going to hurt them more
and that's not good considering the
state of the province epidemiologists
warn of more record-breaking days ahead
as the kovid 19 positivity rate which is
hovering around 9
continues to rise the lockdown was
supposed to ease the burden on hospitals
but icu cases are now so high elective
surgeries are being canceled
in burlington a field hospital built in
april hadn't been needed
until now and morgues in london and
windsor are over capacity
a political controversy is the last
thing ford needs
mike relay global news toronto
still ahead alberta's premier is m.i.a
as
outrage builds over government travel
alberta's premier jason kenney is still
nowhere to be seen
after the travel scandal involving six
of his mlas and his
now former chief of staff two of kenny's
cabinet members have apologized on
behalf of the provincial government
but now calgary's mayor one of the
premier's toughest critics
revealed members of his staff traveled
over christmas too
heather yorks west reports it was the
apology that albertans had been waiting
for
but it did not come from the premier if
you're yelling at us
interestingly enough my message is thank
you
there is no doubt in our mind we didn't
get it right it was left to rick mciver
an alberta cabinet minister now in
charge of two portfolios
after tracy ellard was booted out of the
inner circle for a trip to hawaii
she was demoted along with five other
mlas for spending
christmas abroad outside of social media
posts
jason kenny has not spoken publicly
since new year's day
and his absence has been noticed i just
don't know how you can recover from
something like this
it would be different if it were you
know some
sort of a blip in an otherwise
relatively successful
uh government one that had sort of
momentum on its side
but the momentum has been going the
other direction for months now
but if kenny is in hot water he's no
longer on his own
two members of my staff including
my chief of staff and an administrative
assistant in my office
traveled over the christmas break
calgary's mayor's first response was to
defend his staff
they're not politicians and so
ultimately
i have decided that i will not take any
further action on this
incensed a group in calgary is now
circulating a petition
calling on the city to lift covid
restrictions
if mayor nancy thinks it's fine for his
chief of staff to shop at small
businesses in maui
maybe it's time to lift the restrictions
on small businesses in calgary
as for the premier he'll have to face
the voters eventually
because current health measures expire
soon he has to
address the public before uh january the
12th if he's going to allow for more
freedom he's got to explain why now is
the right time
and if he's going to allow for the
lockdown to continue
he's got to justify that too along with
his reasons for being absent for this
long
heather urex west global news calgary
up next america's capital under a curfew
after a day of chaos
back to tonight's top story the chaos in
the u.s capitol
protesters loyal to president donald
trump stormed the capitol building to
try to stop
congress from confirming joe biden's
victory and tonight the american capitol
is under a curfew president trump did
release a statement telling protesters
to go home but he also repeated the lie
that the election was stolen from him
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow once again joins us this evening
jackson this is really just unbelievable
but should we be surprised by what
unfolded in d.c today
absolutely not robin you know just uh 45
minutes before
the siege of the capitol rudy giuliani
was on a stage outside the white house
at president trump's rally calling for
trial
by combat and this is the type of
rhetoric that has been coming from the
president and his closest allies
and his enablers ever since he lost the
election they have made it clear
that they feel the election was stolen
they have leveled these baseless
accusations
all in an attempt to ramp up trump's
supporters and you know that some people
are simply going to move on
when they realize that trump is lost you
also know that there are people who are
not going to move on from that and take
this as literal incitement and that's
what we saw today
the other thing here robin is that the
security at the capitol complex is going
to face intense scrutiny in this city
for big events like a state of the union
address
that place is a fortress there's a
non-scalable fence that is erected
around the capital complex
for blocks the national guard is here
there are specialized military units
that secure the building
yet despite all the fears despite all
the threats of violence for today's
joint session of congress none of that
was in place none of it
all we saw were capital police defending
the building and low crowd control
barriers and that tells you
that there was simply not enough
security in place for something that was
destined to become violent based on the
rhetoric we've heard over the past
little while
all right jackson prescott washington
thank you so much for today
and that is global national for this
wednesday night a historic day in
washington
i'm robin gill thank you for watching
[Music]